Scotland loved, respected and admired her.
And by all accounts, Her Majesty was really happier...
...than when she was here in Scotland at her beloved Balmoral.
In fact, I have been privileged to observe personally.
I hope it will be a source of comfort to her family...
...that she spent her final days in a place that she loved so much.
I had the opportunity to meet her before she passed...
...and she was an incredibly gracious and decent woman.
The thoughts and prayers of the American people...
...are with the people of the United Kingdom...
...and the Commonwealth and their grief.
She was thoughtful, wise, curious, helpful, funny and so much more.
I feel very similar emotions,...
...both at the same time feeling a sense of deep sadness,...
...but also deep gratitude.
Here is a woman who gave her life utterly to the service of others.
Queen Elizabeth II was the rock on which modern Britain was built.
Our country has grown and flourished under her reign.
Britain is the great country it is today because of her.
Her life of faithful service will be remembered for centuries to come.
From the moment the young princess became Queen,...
...her Majesty's dedication to duty and service over self...
...were the hallmarks of her reign.